[Musique]
m
aujourd'hui la toute nouvelle caméra de
samsung qui sort la caméra à 360 degrés
la nouvelle qui était présenté en même
temps que le iphone est ce que le
samsung galaxy s suite je ne peux pas ne
pas avoir cette caméra
je ne peux pas ne pas faire une vidéo à
360 donc je vais de ce pas les chercher
[Musique]
du nouveau en ce vendredi vendredi 5 mai
c'est aujourd'hui que sortait la
nouvelle caméra à 360 degrés de samsung
elle a été annoncée en même temps que le
galaxy s suite et suit plus
une nouvelle caméra qui doit continuer à
faire entrer encore plus samsung dans
l'ère de la vidéo à 360 degrés et on a
vu lors de leurs comptes se passe-t-il à
regarder alors le lancement de produits
qu effectivement samsung s'adresse
directement aux créateurs conflit et
c'est en ce sens là qui vont toujours
plus loin au niveau des produits qui
propose donc aujourd'hui et le lancement
officiel de cette caméra qui s'annonce
est un produit extraordinaire
j'ai la chance de l'avoir avec moi
la nouvelle samsung jr 360 une nouvelle
caméra qui permet de faire des live
directement sur youtube ou sur facebook
en 4k en 360 degrés on va vraiment faire
des choses top avec ça et laissez-moi
vous dire que je pense qu'on va se
marrer
alors déjà on va regarder le produit en
lui-même parce que le produit est très
beau c'est très bien failli être juste
une toute petite boîte qui est très
élégante en plus sur la façade
on sait très bien que ça parle j 360
mais le fait d'avoir la suite de
l'acadien la nasa en dit long sur
l'histoire effectivement dans le côté
immersion dans le quotidien 160 c'est
une boîte qui est très sympa alors il
précise bien 2010 est ici pour dire que
c'est bien la nouvelle caméra l'ancien
grand bruit suspect de trépied pas très
beau celle ci soutient directement la
main pour aller encore plus loin dans le
storytelling aller encore plus loin dans
l'immersion et je pense qu'avec ce
produit est vraiment la possibilité de
faire des choses qui seront au top donc
un produit qui est très sympa
les côtés anaïs le précise
enregistrements vidéos en 4k 360°
diffusion vidéo en direct à 360
l'utiliser l'instant édition et partage
simplifié
tout en sachant que normalement avec un
logiciel d'édition qui est qu'ils aient
compris avec fabriqués au vietnam par
samsung est derrière la tête
notice explicative filmée et diffusée en
60 en haute définition
qu'est-ce qui a précisé nécessite un
logiciel pour smartphone ou ordinateur
windows ou mac compatibles et
télécharger l'application pour
smartphone samsung jir 360 la galaxie
apps plastor webster donc même avec un
iphone je peux la piloter directement
c'est génial l'application pour
smartphone est disponible pour elle si
elle suit ensuite plus est cette es7
neige
ed s'cusez moi s6 et plus et 6 et 6
aides à 5 et la sangle 2017 a précisé
télécharger l'application pour
ordinateurs jr depuis samsung ou
nécessite une carte microsd carte classe
10 minimum recommandé jusqu'à 256
gigaoctets plus d'informations la
samsung point com voilà ce qu'on peut
voir sur l'extérieur se produit je te
lis à tout petit très sympa très compact
avec une petite poignée c'est vraiment
un packaging qui est très jolie
maintenant on va regarder ce que cette
caméra ce que ce petit paquet a dans le
ventre
donc voilà un produit on va regarder ce
qu'il a directement dans le ventre non
on va rire directement ici tu as le
petit saut
on restait sur six aux as yes alors on
va aussi des corps d'éventuelles doubles
autant pour moi lui on se dit on se
voile par là alors je t'ouvre l'autre
côté à 6,6 il est temps de faire tu dois
pas très doux avec ce truc bordel de
bordel de bordel de bordel
voilà c'est tout vert petit livret
samsung annonce l'ouverture de la boîte
samsung et quand tu ouvres la caméra est
ici tu la vois très très jolie tu vois
c'est vraiment un petit objet c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est tout
petit con pas de place donc je pense que
tu peux emmener relativement partout
produit très sympa alors la petite
caméra gier
ah ouais elle est vraiment minuscule
ducrocq qu'on regarde à la taille de la
main c'est incroyable tu la tiens dans
la main tu peux vraiment l'emmener je
pense où tu veux c'est vraiment le coup
de tout objet elle fait quand même son
poids c'est pas le truc trop léger alors
cette caméra
déjà tu peux la fixer sur un pied là tu
vois déjà qui cite à l'emplacement pour
c'est très bien le petit port ici pour
le brancher
je pense qu'on vivait le slot pour la
carte
voilà c'est à micro micro sd j'ai une
micro sd
je la positionne est parfait donc le
petit ce mode pour la micro sd que tu as
ici et que je vais repositionner sans
faire de conneries à l'instant le numéro
de série à l'avant un petit écran pour
voir se lancer l'enregistrement
ici tu dois pouvoir imposer une dragonne
je pense un pour plus de sécurité un
bouton back enregistrements a priori un
bouton menu avec le logo bluetooth la
petite caméra sur le côté voilà le
principal vue du dessus ça doit être les
micros à mon ami qui sont ils sont
positionnés là les ont toujours le
produit en lui même
alors voyons voir maintenant ce qu'il ya
dans le reste du paquet on a ici une
guide de prise en main rapide voit sa
autocollantes etc autocollantes et je
sais pas
ce qu'ils ont voulu faire avec ce truc
d'accord ok alors les cours à l'école
alors libre de prise en main en français
ça c'est le gars outils regard devient
dingue
bon je te passe le guide de prise en
main je vais l'étudier parce que je
pense que tout de suite là directement
ça ne va pas intéresser ce qui va être
vraiment intéressant je pense avec la la
gestion logicielle la gestion des live
tout ça je regarderai on en reparlera un
peu plus tard le petit câble usb
effectivement pour pouvoir brancher ta
caméra directement à comps d'ordinateurs
ça ça doit être la dragonne si je ne
trouve pas alors à savoir la petite
blague sommes effectivement tu vas aller
mettre directement de fûts ça je sais
pas c'est pas connu
sur itunes mais un ouvrage sais pas
comment ça marche la dragonne et là au
fond ça doit être un étui iem en asie
portatif pour la protéger si l'on fait
les choses bien ça doit ressembler à ça
cette espèce de chaussettes
c'est une très très belle chaussettes
comme tu peux le remarque que ce n'est
pas un c'est pas un préservatif j'allais
dire voilà donc je pense que tu fous ta
caméra d'or cela protège et cette hargne
effectivement de la transporter en toute
sécurité
et c'est plutôt bien foutu voilà
l'emballage on a fait le tour on a un
petit peu tout regarder ce qu'on va
faire d'ailleurs dès demain ce que je
ferai demain je vais faire la première
vidéo à 360 de la chaîne donc si tu as
des lunettes vr tu vas pouvoir équiper
directement pour pouvoir regarder ça tu
peux tu me diras ce que tu en penses
si t'as pas lunettes vertes que prof
pour smartphones et tabac là des comme
ça donc ce sera quand même en immersion
t'inquiète pas les toute façon ça marche
très bien cette manière là demain
première vidéo je vais essayer de
trouver des coins un peu sympa où
effectivement la 360 se marient et en
attendant je vais m'entraîner ce soir
pour voir déjà un petit peu comment ce
fonctionne c'est cette caméra
c'est vrai que l'objet je te le dire est
vraiment compact à tous les siens dans
la main c'est vraiment un tout petit
produit hyper agréable à prendre
je pense qu'avec ça il ya moyen de faire
des choses extraordinaires
je vais essayer de faire ce truc là
dedans soit généralement c'est toujours
le
deux choses qui t'énerve la dragonne qui
passent des heures et ça ne marche pas
je le ferai plus tard quand chacun la
petite caméra très sympa alors ce qu'il
faut et j'ai acheté aussi parce que je
l'avais pas c'est le casque de réalité
virtuelle samsung puis fonctionne celui
ci pourrait 6è cette galaxy note cette
es7 edge est 6 h + s6 edge y en a un qui
vient de sortir aussi là cette année
pour le le et suit l es suis plus qui a
une petite télécommande en plus celui-ci
ne l'a pas mais bossard pas très très
bien à faire de toute façon je n'ai pas
de galaxies et suite j'ai uniquement le
s7 de justin que je pouvoir utiliser
comme ça ça me permettra effectivement
de tester le truc est de voir comment ça
marche et je pense que ça va ça va
déchirer
j'ai hâte parce que vraiment ça fait
très longtemps que je vois des vidéos
passé on réalise en 360 qu'est ce que je
vois sur les réseaux sociaux
et j'ai pleinement accès je pense que ça
va justifier d'un lien
tu vois le casque alors après t'as pas
l'air content ça sur la tronche ans
alors j'ai essayé le casque playstation
pour la pour la ps4
au mois de septembre ou octobre de tête
du sable du monde de l'auto à paris
il fermait mieux c'était mieux mieux
faire mais au niveau du port du casque
après tout c'est à tout le monde que
mais bon je pense que ce n'est pas
dérangeant
je pense que c'est pas dire aux gens à
voir en tout cas vent et là dedans si
vous avez atteint jusque avait dedans si
vous connaissez pas il doit y avoir
effectivement
enfin la tâche à la tâche est perdu mais
aujourd'hui les temps un petit
adaptateur qui doit servir effectivement
à brancher
le casque et accessoires voilà voilà un
peu tous cas là dedans donc c'est
vraiment la grande nouveauté en ce
moment c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
l'a développé énormément la 360 tu vois
qu'elle plus en plus de photos qui se
font en panoramique 360
la vidéo est en train vraiment une honte
et en en gamme l'iphone sortira
probablement la version 2018
normalement avec un casque divers aussi
donc ça c'est vraiment cartonné de se
développer je pense qu'il va y avoir
plein de films qui vont sortir aussi en
360 en immersion complète les jeux vidéo
aussi donc voilà je skie prend
énormément d'ampleur donc je voulais pas
louper le coche
ça me plait énormément je pense qu'on va
se marrer ce rendez vous des deux mains
sur la chaîne pour regarder la toute
première vidéo en 360
si j'ai réussi à m'en sortir si je me
suis sortie du logiciel de montage
l'egypte entre ça devrait le faire merci
d'avoir regardé la vidéo dis moi ce que
tu penses toi aussi tu as hâte devant la
360 c'est quelque chose qui m'intéresse
pas ce que tu as des lunettes de vr est
ce que tes équipes et voilà dix mois
tout tu mets tout en commentaire
merci d'abord regarder la vidéo à benoît
à la chelle ses contenus plaît et puis
je te dis à de bas parce que demain
franchement ça va envoyer du steak
allez ciao
[Musique]